hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm katie du
Bois we're gonna do some fun video today
what is it what is it Katie it's calling
out slow wets sorry I feel a little bit
drowsy because I'm a little sick right
now they're just making me joke around a
little funny a little fun fun is this
cuz you know I like Cowboys is that
where this is coming from this unless
you like it yeah that's right you like
Cowboys you you have sex with Cowboys
Cowboys are awesome I would totally have
sex with the cowboy yeah yeah exactly
right anyway Michael Fassbender stars in
this okay Jane
once upon a time Jay Cavendish traveled
from cold shoulder of Scotland the
baking heart America to find his love a
jackrabbit and den of wolves arms abroad
boy sir I'm Jay Cavendish son of Lady
Cavendish we're all sounds a big if you
paid my solo it'll be dead by dawn take
care of myself sure kid you need
chaperones let's drift ya know why I'm
headed west look it was an accident this
is cool was all my child
I got a new father fled from Scotland I
wouldn't know where we are nobody knows
who we are the body hunters what do they
want what money $2,000 Isis a certain
breed of undesirable just want painting
here band recovery yeah what North big
trouble hey man up with that there's
more selects I'm surviving yep there's
dying no [ __ ] 3px bush deep in the West
take over any rock
desperado full of life you right in the
heart
I'll kill you
wanna say so not bad kid dad ah looked
awesome yeah that you think it's gonna
be like about a poet you know yeah a
lovely English cottage and then it's a
badass Wes yeah and it's a badass
western that looks totally unique I love
badass westerns I've used to binge watch
westerns when i was younger i love that
these actors are look all really unique
and believable you know just like good
mugs I'm some of these actors and then
this super young guy I wouldn't have
expected him to be the lead and like a
badass Western like this but there he is
I love Michael Fassbender he's one of my
favorites out there right now yeah so
sexy in like every single thing he does
and the see him as like the badass
gunslinger and this you know like oath
starius one mysterious cowboy you know
that's what's awesome about this a lot
like Django Unchained was the [ __ ] like
True Grit was cool Genrich ain't had a
lot of humor but I've been wanting a
Western like a modern-day take on just a
traditional badass western and that's
what this feels like to me is it doesn't
seem like a ripoff of westerns it seems
like it's paint on module and it's like
updating traditional badass western
story yeah I know this is kind of gonna
sound weird but it kind of reminds me of
crouching tiger hidden dragon hero like
these movies you know these like
Japanese movies that are have like huge
sweeping cinematic like when they were
standing in the in the wheat and it was
up to their armpits and they're like
shooting through it just seemed really
expansive to me and usually westerns
don't have that much texture like
westerns are usually just like some dry
Hollywood Hills because they're probably
shooting like right outside the city but
this looks like the locations were like
so rich and interesting Katie you were
right that was weird too far that was
weird I'm weird
yeah you have successfully done it you
said before you got into this yeah that
this might sound kind of weird it wasn't
so the whole time i was listening going
is this weird we have learned yes that
is weird it is what valid I'm weird okay
valid valid fell a bit strange yes
that's me I like to think I'm an
intellectual critic okay all right if
you guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects katie has
a channel just fast 500 subscribers with
d new Jesus for you and you can follow
us on facebook twitter and you can
follow me on instagram because this is
how don't know why she'd go and yo you
shouldn't have Bob your head to that
that was like an inside was into it and
you know until then and that is like a
serious side of childhood trauma and I
would totally get that looked into you
all right I'm telling you my therapist
damn solve your problems like no one's
business group therapy we're going to
Gert you're going to your hair